[Musique]
qu'est ce nouveau record est seconde 102
nous sommes cette journée va être
affreux
[Musique]
on peut être quelque chose tiens ça
m'apporte courtois non moi c'est non
moi
waouh
revient à [ __ ] ma main je me sens
presque plus bas je me sens plus du tout
maintenant je sais pas là toutes ses
frappes ces bons vieux supporter de lens
je vois la connexion de l'application
pas non maintenant des nouvelles
négatives les fesses bien actuellement
datant de près de deux millions
d'abonnés nom de leurs membres warteck
est un canon à l'idée de voir le pape
dit qu'il a trop pressés sur la gâchette
prenons merveilles de notre reporter
c'est même pas vrai d'abord j'ai juste
trop joué qu'une fille hier soir au lait
et des mains pour muse de pixels avec
nos jeunes étaient super fins militaires
[Musique]
du ma c'est pas un candidat suivant
voyez prendre place
bonjour présente toi s'il te plait je
m'appelle jean pierre weiss empire 14-18
cadence de baisser avec youtube y était
peut-être lucquin de la motte
j'ai actuellement 17 ans et ma passion
c'est l'opéra très bien tu peux y aller
[Musique]
enfin c'est pour ça que je suis
actuellement plutôt combat du jour la
france 2 nous vous aimez non non pas du
tout c'est à dire nous revoici donc dans
l'émission qui veut gagner des taux
qu'elle commence et je suis aujourd'hui
avec un invité très spécial puisqu'il ne
veut pas le dire son ombre tu veux
toujours pas me le dire vraiment alors
nous en sommes donc à la question pour
un million de tocane donc ça représente
quand même beaucoup d'xp ses passe-temps
est conscient ou pas mais la question de
la suivante
concentre toi bien dans call of duty
qu'est ce qui arrive le plus souvent
bien que son souffle
ferrette marqueur réponse b faire une
cote film raiponce et avoir une seule
connexion ce qui est très embêtant
comptant huit filets et réponses des se
prendre un tel un bombardier furtif dont
je trouve
as tu une petite idée tu n'as pas petite
idée en tête tu te lâches dès que
quelqu'un me de vidéos en ligne
vous avez vraiment génial la réponse
c'est foutu
fait du crossfit mai mais c'est vrai
qu'on a fait
[Musique]
un colloque 2 ça ne peut pas faire du
mal on ne sait pas vraiment là c'est bon
je voulais écouter de la musique je
revienne un peu les clics
eh ben mon gars dans six red meat et des
tyrans co pour te faire chier
[Musique]
j'aime pas les lance grenades
j'aime pas les ump de ne pas les
marathons commando poids léger je parle
et si l'exclusivité ça
je me croire je m'appelle warfare au
tout j'aime bien jouer avec nous par m
les fonds c'est tous ces pauvres gens
les crues
les gens mais pour tout ça il faut que
je guiga pas tant
et partout sur toile offre je veux qu'on
parle de moi je m'étais peut soit vue on
se souvient de moi et m'a dire que je
vous tue
je voudrais me parle que
[Musique]
et quand j'arrive pas jouer je m'énerve
sur la télé ensuite ça passe au cdh
finit par le balancer et je suis dégoûté
je n'ai plus qu'à me racheter
[Musique]
oh